ah c'est une tribune avec les meilleures
bouteilles qui fait la une du figaro
yquem smith la fuite puis nîmes en a
chez roadrunner 60 meilleurs crus en
veulent à agnès buzyn ce que vous
laissez faire vous voyez ces lettres
vous pouvez le lire c'est la
transformation d'un produit d'excellence
distribuée dans le monde entier en un
bien délictueux à travers la position de
pictogrammes mortifère sur les femmes
enceintes et les mineurs voici donc ce
que dit cette tribune notamment en cause
l'agrandissement en fait d'un
pictogramme qui est obligatoire depuis
une dizaine d'années qui montre que le
vin est dangereux pour les femmes
enceintes
actuellement il est d'un demi centimètre
et il doit être sa taille doit être
augmentée à plus d'un centimètre
une signalétique lugubre mortifère qui
nous associe à des substances mortifère
disent donc les auteurs de la tribune
bref le ruinart bordeaux blanc associé
au lsd
voilà en tout cas la justification de la
ministre je crois que les femmes
enceintes ne savent pas qu'aujourd'hui
l'alcool passe directement le placenta
et vont alcoolisées le bébé ça ne
viendrait à l'esprit de personne de
maître de l'alcool dans un biberon or
quand on boit de l'alcool et qu'on est
enceinte
eh bien on nourrit son bébé son site us
d'alcool et donc je pense que là il ya
une prime sur toutes les bouteilles
femmes enceintes qui existent déjà qui
ajoute que fille mais qui sera que
personne n'est parti sera plus grand
nous négocions hervé nathan bas alors là
ça vous met de l'ambiance
hervé nathan vous êtes 20 ou bien je
suis 20 et busin et je pense que même si
ces points de vue en france on a vu ici
pour une fois pour une fois pour cette
fois sur ce sujet là c'est madame butin
qui a raison pour deux raisons d'abord
je suis allé voir ce le fit le site
figaro point santé parce que
je situe pas très bien le cigare au
point son excellente habitude excitant
est malade et donc à des résultats
sérieux dit exactement ce que dit madame
busin et donne tous les arguments à
buzeins s'éteint c'est très dangereux
pour les femmes non pas pour les femmes
enceintes mais pour le bébé à venir
voilà et les statistiques les études
scientifiques vont toutes dans le même
sens il n'ya pas de dose minimale il ya
pas de dose maximum et c'est ce que bois
la mer le foetus la boisse et le site
allemand sur la reprise est là ça qu'on
reproche non mais leur approche et je
crois que les femmes enceintes ne savent
pas mais c'est ça qui sont apparemment
et donc je crois que ça veut dire ça
c'est bien la preuve que non parce que
voilà la vraie la prévention elle passe
à leur santé leur ailleurs je vais voilà
l'autre sujet moi j'ai quoi j'ai vu le
sujet qui est passé je me suis rappelé
la propagande et fabricants de tabac
c'est exactement la même c'était
exactement dumas steve c'était vous
présenter un produit qui était un
produit sympathie qui permet la récré la
création que tout le monde l'utilisé
terrain où présenter ça comme un danger
oui l'alcool pour les fours les foetus
c'est très dangereux
c'est très dangereux voilà et donc il
faut faire en sorte que les femmes
enceintes et allaitantes ailleurs
enceintes et allaitantes je rappelle le
figaro présente et s'abstiennent
totalement de boire parce que la
recommandation du site sans fil hier au
point santé c'est abstinence complète
c'est pas on peut en voir un petit peu
l'énoncé 0 voilà et donc moi je lis mais
en tant que lecteur du figaro point
sante.fr je trouve que c'est il faut il
fuir
voilà ce que nous propose d'élargir
votre votre lecture au figaro magazine
et donner la chose que les femmes
enceintes soient interdits de lecture de
certains ouvrages jeu pourquoi de
rabelais de balzac de flaubert soit
interdit de regarder certains tableaux
on voit des bouteilles il n'y a pas de
pictos disant que les femmes enceintes
ne doivent pas voir devin on est quand
même dans une société avec ce principe
de précaution arrivée dans la
constitution mais qui prend une ampleur
démesurée parce que c'est très bien mais
on arrête ou le curseur de dire que le
vin est dangereux pour les femmes
enceintes il faut le mettre partout en
ce moment partout encore d'accord dans
la littérature dans les arts dans le
cinéma en plus peut faire un film comme
cédric klapisch
mais non mais par exemple on est en
train d'interdire le cas on est en train
de limiter la vitesse à 80 km/heure et
par exemple pourrait prendre une mesure
qui sans doute ferez baisser nettement
la mortalité sur les routes c'est
l'interdiction totale de l'alcool on
entend pendant qu'on y est on est assez
récent match et logan % des tués ont 30%
des russes mais il ya des perturbations
exception c'est totalement interdit
voilà ça n'empêche pas les gens de boire
de l'alcool quand il en a envie mais par
en conduisant est bien desservi mais là
il s'agit pas d'interdiction c'est un
pictogramme c'est une information que
vous êtes contre la formation alors que
nous faisons le métier d'informer mais
promis je vous laisse je vais comme on
exporte du verseau gens qui ne veulent
pas cette armée nation c'est une
émission des internautes mais la cedh
rappelle vous êtes en train de défendre
le lay les plus gros groupes mondialisés
de l'alcool sur mai 68 dont on parle des
68 s'entend pas le font tous leur
chiffre d'affaires à l'extérieur du pays
d'ailleurs leur argumentaire c'est de
dire laissez nous participe au festin de
la mondialisation nous empêcher de
surtout pas mais les français peuvent
plus payer savoir une fois qu'on évoque
le château yquem personne peut en voir
en france ce quasiment pas we don t y en
a marre ça vous vous défendez vous dire
qu'il y avait des jeux vous défendez les
profits au départ mais de la santé
reviendra si je veux bien que ces
quelques femmes
du camarade vecchio là mais je veux bien
croire qu'il ya quelques femmes
enceintes qui ne sont pas au courant
voilà à tellement n'arriveront problèmes
d'éducation quand même ça prend l'airé
des civilisations et c'est pas la taille
du pictogramme qui va le résoudre et
encore moins sur les grands crus parce
que franchement on offre à sarrians
grand cru non je ne pense pas que les
femmes qui ne savent pas que c'est
dangereux consomme consomme des vins du
cru et après c'est vrai que c'est
peut-être moins mal c'est ce que oui ça
fait peut-être ça s'inscrit quand même
dans une politique hygiéniste et
justement de la mesure sur les 15 à 20
km/heure au politique en un tabac dans
les films etc et donc le voilà c'est la
politique réduite à la taille du
pictogramme je pense que les politiques
sont impuissants dans le lobby du juge
avoir raison d'eux les vrais problèmes
ont choisi le biais de rééduquer le jour
convient que je n'ai pas peur je me dis
que c'est là qu'il est présent à
l'elysée vous savez très bien que la
conseillère la conseiller agriculture et
pas vous avez vous l'apprendre donc la
conseillère et culture la même enseigne
en agriculture de 2,2 du président de la
république
elle était la directrice du lobby du vin
qui s'appelle vin et société et qui
avant d'être à l'elysée faisait campagne
pour l'association interprofessionnelle
s'assure interventionnelle et qui
faisait campagne donc moi ça me tente
pas tout à fait un hasard si nous avons
la foi cette magnifique c'est cette
magnifique tribune de soixante quatre
grands domaines viticoles qui ne vend
quasiment jamais en france parce que
c'est trop cher pour le public français
en tout cas pour 90 % de la population
et qui d'ailleurs si vous regardez
l'argumentaire que qui est dans votre
journal
qu'est ce qu'ils disent ils disent
ouvrant des comptes nous sommes sains
produits mondialisés ben oui c'est un
produit mondialisé mais de la santé
publique ce n'est pas le problème des
grands groupes mondialisés c'est
beaucoup de gens rêvent l'industrie du
genre de pitonner quatre clubs et il a
pas l'air très figurait la seita fait
évincer la secte a dans le temps faisait
me faisait beaucoup varié beaucoup
d'ouvriers en france c'est pour ça
qu'ils ont tant à la mer c'est tout le
monde sait que je sers au caire dans ma
captivité
sachez
alors je reviens maintenant que les
esprits sans avoir bu je tiens à le dire
ces deux se sont échauffés je tiens à
dire que c'est une émission dédiée aux
internautes et que nick me dit tout le
monde sait qu'une femme enceinte ne doit
pas boire ni fumer si les gens sont
stupides c'est du darwinisme ça c est ce
qu on pourrait faire de dix pattes
pareil dans la malbouffe dans ces cas là
richard bouillon n'a pas eu la parole
mais je n'étais pas si le nom donc c'est
bien qu'elle passerait mais en tdm et je
n'ai pas de références de françois
hollande donc j'ai préféré attendre sur
ce coup là non mais je jamais de faire
une blague à la françois hollande non
nous est pas possible et il est trop
fort
donc je redis sur le débat en fait il
est il y avait enfin il est intéressant
et peut-être plus important qu'on il
qu'on ne le croit
d'abord je pense que si maintenant très
bien moi je ne suis pas opposé à ce qui
est des campagnes de santé publique de
prévention public et qu'elle soit
organisée et qu'à un moment donné elle
vise à mettre sur des produits qui sont
potentiellement dangereux pour des
utilisateurs des avertissements et que
ce soit des avertissements qui soit
plutôt visible et lisible on l'a sur les
paquets de cigarettes je je je trouve
pas ça complètement délirant que ce soit
posée de même que si on trouve
que sur les bouteilles de vin il faut un
meilleur étiquetage pourquoi pas le seul
truc c'est que je comprends ni la
méthode ni le fait de dire que un
centimètre et demi où je sais pas
combien tout d'un coup va faire la
différence terre que autant je pense que
l'internaute qui vous interpeller autant
je pense que l'internaute qui vous
interpellez se trompe en disant que
toutes les femmes savent non toutes les
femmes ne savent pas et je pense qu'il
faut organes total s'annonce une femme
et j'ai eu mon premier entraîneur 160
est évident je savais la fallait pas
manquer ce parce que vous êtes bien
informé parce que vous allez sur le site
info santé du cigare au mais je
ressentais pareil je suis allé moi tard
dans les revues mais je suis allé avant
cette émission parce que je suis pas un
spécialiste de ce sujet je suis allé sur
le site du monde.fr
et qu'est ce que nous dit le site du
monde un que ça existe depuis 2007 et
donc que la polémique elle est un petit
peu étonnante que deux mais c'est aussi
des bonnes c'est aussi des bonnes
sources d'information dans un pluralisme
il est là mais pas françois deuxième en
disent quoi
en fait cette mesure allait quand même
enfin le fait de ne pas boire pendant
qu'on est en elle est plutôt bien
comprise de la part des français et
quand on a des sondages
on a en gros un nombre important de
personnes qui disent que effectivement
il n'est pas bon pour une femme enceinte
de bois ou de fumer ou autre pourtant il
ya une partie qui ne savent pas et sur
cette partie là je pense que la ministre
veut cibler donc je trouve pas ça
complètement déformée moi c'est la
méthode que je enfin en ce moment c'est
là c'est la semaine de colocation
pression à la fois sur la du monde afin
d'ôter un peu maîtresse d'école
c'est le côté maîtresse écoles ses côtés
pourquoi un thème comme ça on est pas
sur une concertation pourquoi sur un
thème comme ça alors que c'est
normalement ça dois je crois aboutir à
la fin de l'année on a des privés des
préconisations qui doit vous dire
pourquoi sortir maintenant pourquoi elle
sortir comme ça alors qu'elle s'y
pertinemment qu'elle va se taper une
partie des lobbys et qu'elle n'a pas en
face le soutien de ceux qui pourraient
par contre la défendre qui sont
notamment l'ensemble des professions et
médicales herminator je vous donnerai la
parole sur ça mais je voudrais qu'on
aborde le dernier des sujets parce qu'on
peut pas y échapper
c'est là